ok I want to talk about a very old
problem it's gone by different names one
of them is the theorem on friends and
strangers so what we're going to do is
Brady we're going to update this for the
kids make the kind of hip we're not
going to talk about adults at a dinner
party we're going to talk about people
on Facebook oh yeah yeah all right get
down with that
you down with 1 billion people on
Facebook we've got 6 people on Facebook
ok there's more than 6 people on
Facebook you know that now there's
certain relationships you can have you
can either be connected which we're
going to say is green okay so this
dude's connected to this 3rd this
person's connected this person this
person's connected this person or you're
not so you're like this guy doesn't know
this person this person's blocked this
person this person here doesn't know
they exist this person they don't even
speak the same language ok so this is
this is the situation now if we think
about if we're now going to try and
count how many different arrangements we
can have of 6 anonymous people on
Facebook
so there's actually 15 different
connections between people but each
connection is either your friends or
you're not friends to count that we
actually though 2 to the power 15 ok so
that's what that that's how to count how
many we've got so that number is 3 to 7
6 8 so you got 15 lines each one can
either be a friend or not a friend sorry
only friends with you don't try and stop
requested any friends I don't wanna be
friends with you ok no this is you this
is your mom and it's like no mum go away
this is your dad it's like you know
we're connected in the house not on
Facebook you drew that quite randomly
yep there were 30 there were nearly 33
thousand different ways you could have
done that there's exactly 32 768
different ways you can do that brady
don't round it up
so obviously you could have like I don't
know it's like you could have like one
direction right and their manager they'd
all be green they're all connected and
then if you've got like the like members
of your family like we
before nobody's connected a lot of
complexity on Facebook if you think
about all those different connections
but just looking at a very small subset
it's just six people look how look how
many connections we've got so the
question is what can we say about every
single possible permutation every single
possible combination is anything that we
can glean because we want to try and
find order out of chaos as
mathematicians we want to go what can we
learn about any possible one if you gave
me one of these at random what could I
say without even looking at it okay go I
know exactly something about it so what
we can say about any random arrangement
of friendships or not friendships we can
say for any single one any of these
32,000 768 there's always three people
that are friends or three people that
are not friends
but it could be more and it could be
more because like in the One Direction
band manager thing there's lots of
groups of three right but the point is
is that it's in at least so at least
means okay this is the absolute minimum
so either three people or friends or 3
people are not friends and that's the
order that we can do so why is there a
reason behind that can we prove it we
can okay so this is how we're going to
prove it first of all we're going to try
and simplify things okay so now let's
just look at one this is too complicated
let's just look at one guy okay one
person so one person has his like could
be friends here we're just looking at
the connections I don't want to color
them up just yet so it's like one two
three four five so you think okay so
what can we know about these friendships
that this person has with all these
people we've got five lines and we want
to know what color are they is going to
be green are they going to be dotted red
they're going to be friends or not
friends so if we look at five we could
actually see all right we could just
start kind of counting in a funny way so
we can kind of go oh yeah there's a
situation where there could be five or
friends and then this guy's not not
friends with no
okay popular it's popular yeah yeah yeah
he's friends with everybody
okay he's a bit of an Obama he's a
politician that's when this is this is
the politician here he's friends with
everybody the other one could be instead
it could be his friends with four people
and he's not friends with one person so
you can keep going like this and now
actually we can just fill this out here
so we get three two one zero
and one two three four five this is the
different ways we can do it now if we
look at every single possibility there
so here we know one of the at least
things so here we know look if it's five
friends and and zero not friends well we
know that that is that's definitely
greater than three friends there for or
that's greater than three friends there
three that's greater than three friends
there - well that's not greater than
three friends there but now it's greater
than three not friends and this is
greater than three not friends and this
is greater than three much friends so
you know that any way you break this up
or any combination of like friends or
not friends there's always one person is
always friends with at least three
people or not friends with at least
three people and that's the kind of
tricky bit if you can get your head
around that the next bit should be cool
so let's just draw up another random
anonymous just to kind of keep it clean
here's our guy here
so let's actually say he is friends with
at least three people or it could be the
opposite right but we're going to go his
friends with this person he's friends
with this person and he's friends with
this person now what we want to do is
we're going to try and force the worst
situation okay so what we're trying to
do is we're trying to show that that the
the theorem says at least three people
know each other or at least three people
don't know each other so let's try and
let's try and push it to the extreme so
in that sense it's like we want to try
and make sure that we don't want three
people to know each other to be friends
on Facebook so that means we are going
to go okay so if this guy this guy
the sky what all friends they would all
be green we don't want that we want
these ones to be red so we put a - red
line there these guys aren't friends
but there's another triangle here so
it's green green no no we don't want you
to be friends all right of course you're
trying to you're trying to avoid a
threesome at all costs we are trying to
avoid a threesome at all cost that's
exactly right Brady so here we don't
want these guys to be friends but look
there's another triangle there so now we
don't want these guys to be friends but
look what's happened by trying to avoid
this guy making we've created
inadvertently we've actually created
three people that don't know each other
we've created like a threesome of
anonymity which was the other which was
our own door which is a handle and you
can see now if we flipped it if now this
guy wasn't friends noise engines frozen
fins and we made these guys friends it
would be the opposite situation so this
is order out of chaos for every single
possible 32,768 every possible
combination of being friends or not
friends it's always the case you always
find a clique of three people that are
friends with one another or three people
can't stand each other or don't know
each other or are your mum and your dad